oh oh oh oh les années non je ne suis
pas le père noël juste un minuteur
plutôt nabil danseurs et les gens si
vous êtes sur cette vidéo assurez vous
d'avoir vu la partie 1 pour bien
comprendre le délire de la vidéo à
savoir un parc d'attractions mind quoi
flammes
et puis bah surtout ne pas louper nos
précédents délire voila voila je vous
laisse clic et si vous n'avez pas vu
lappartient et sinon c'est parti pour la
partie commence en veulent au plus tard
je troll bloqué mais on est bloqué à
cause de ton mannschaft avait décembre
alors à gros cube qu'est ce que c'est
que ces délires allez on monte mais tu
sais que tu sais quoi
et les vieux trucs en équilibre à la
base d' aller à c'est pas un accro
branches dit ok d'accord sauf qu'il est
de faire comme moi je fais un gros cube
j'adore les semailles allait bien hop
j'ai réussi vas-y ont fait le suivant
effectivement oh là là [ __ ] c'est quoi
au maire au nom en fuite mais revenons
en objet drop hutin un mec c'est
possible mais ça paraissait bien bien
bien bien madame hermès halak trop moi
pour que je puisse faire quoique mais
non regarde regarde les highways électro
je ne pourrais jamais le faire ça les
fosses tu bosses tu as un truc a tenté
ou way vas-y
basée à bien et ici je me tp sur toi
voilà oui là je tp en [ __ ] ça va être
chaud là monsieur choufleuri quoi
wallonie merde quoi majeur mais
j'hallucine
allait-il coup tu pousses un tueur tu
veux qu'on parle d'épisodes ou trois
erreurs de jeunesse on est blanc a
annoncé bon non écrite mais on peut
remonter la haye d'accord on peut
recommencer de là on a perdu c'est super
mais je suis sûr qu un [ __ ] de train
fantôme pierre buffat le roller coaster
technique c'est ça le truc en bois je
suis sûr que c'est après ça que le à huy
après après je dis ça je dis rien [ __ ]
attentes en chine
merde t'es nul à temps un mec mais
j'avoue ça doit être là aucun indice ou
quoi ah oui à moubarak
ouais mais la flemme vas-y à tort moi je
vais faire le roller coaster et jean
vauchère avec toi et le rouge la bombe
rouge et blanc le rouge oui je crois
et si les points bas faut qu'on le fasse
a bien motivés là à part dont on regarde
qui pourrait tout allait super bien fait
la main qu'ils ont dû tellement galéré
les gens qui l'ont fait métrage les en
tout cas et je les respecte un là pour
le coup et sont d'un magasin à wissant
mais c'est bon le début et c'est là bas
c'est là-bas alors mais c'est la seule
fois où tu peux tu as pas besoin de
faire la queue aux joueurs un joueur 2 c
ou org
deux joueurs vas-y métaux championnat je
suis dedans et près 1
ouais il ya un bouton 2 3 way
oui oui à tel aviv et le brouillage je
suis là où olalalala c'est tellement les
clapets oui de manivelle à la volée mais
sa mère
albeau la légion en plus soit oui mais
nous sommes tout un peu à pied au moment
de faire en colère mais je voulais voir
ça faisait quoi les manivelles à ok
d'accord tu peut désactiver le tchad
j'adore aller trop bien cette nappe vrai
franchement c'est quoi ce truc là bas à
temps j'arrive de seconde je t'attends
tu vas bat est arrivé assez tard vu
qu'elle remanie leçons n'ont pas
longtemps mec oui ils se rendent mais
[ __ ] et roanne cheville direct qui
sent super atteint infléchie en plus au
total war et marion woodcraft et folk
auster vas-y vas-y les chiens devaient à
l'ensemble mais avec l'épreuve du bac on
va pas pouvoir
moi j'avoue c'est un peu la galère
godman conseil à phonebusters occasions
d'affaires total woodcraft à loïc raf
l'euthanasie ah c'est pas genre total
wipeout ont remixé oh ouais mais que
c'est ça fait beaucoup le splash ses
trucs et glisse vase et
c'est pourri ok d'accord j'ai rien dis
oh là j'étais un truc qui fait qu'on
n'est pas au couriat je crois c'est trop
bien pour s'être joints titre steve hall
à la hâte en attendant j'ai adoré faire
du hautbois viêt attend un mec j'ai
envie de réussir
mais c'est trop dur mais c'est un fait
quoi moi je vais tout rocher d'un coup
et un autre à temps
au suivant non là je regarde je suis au
bout à twitter va jobs couleur saumon
baltard comme pour la bâche
oui
j'arrive pas comment je retourne moi
j'ai réussi
bonjour c'est super dur sans dec
ai-je fait un blog mais c'est impossible
mais j'ai été super dur j'ai réussi mot
sur un défaut y aller pour y arriver à
temps au regard des prêts à donner pour
tomi cela dit je te regarde
oh bah tiens je vais vous raconter plus
le choix attends attends je suis tombé
au nom mais mec mais c'est pas possible
là haut mais j'y arriverai jamais il est
trop dure à temps pour toi parce que tu
es tellement nuls
tam a en fait je souffre beaucoup trop
tôt quoi aussi quand ça se rabat
bon moi j'ai réussi au pays après près
par contre c'est super dur
ouais non mais quel nom mais plus âgées
voir là où va abandonner le mec qui
roule 45000 repeater ou je sais pas quoi
penser super vite là à moi j'ai à
bordeaux a tenté il ya une manière
beaucoup plus sa mémoire
tu va péter le mur cook est à l'orage
bah oui j'ai envie de voir ce qu'un tel
métier tout écraser ok j'ai compris au
sauter en kart public et sur le suivant
pourrait monter salut des bars et la
haye un bruit horrible
oui oui je sais pas mais [ __ ] mais
mais que ça ramène moi j'aime bien moi
j'ai faillit pas je me suis archi fail
je suis dégoûté hayat en belgique ou
ailleurs là où je veux pas m'emmener bas
mais attends moi j'étais tombé comme une
grosse merde hein se voyait ses bons au
[ __ ] mais allez faire quoi
[ __ ] en fait faut cliquer à chaque
fois sur le mannequin le man car d'après
pardon oui le manoir ça va coller à
l'est mais moi [ __ ] non mais ils sont
sérieux on va fêter on est en train de
saccager la map voilà c'est mon chute
dans tu veux m'en vais à temps sinon
ehtp taille les capitaux carte quoi il
était bleu mais bon je vais à pied
sprinter jump or n'ont en effet pas
égaux à dans des vrais
oh
je suis john ferren poissy mais t'as pas
le temps mais si tu as le temps j'ai pas
le temps aux deux fermes des télégraphes
un château mais faut être aussi rapide
que flash non non tu as pas tant ce pas
possible non franchement j'y crois pas
mais enfin on ne lâchera d'ailleurs
ballon de plage
alors franchement c'est pas possible
mais [ __ ] le trait qu'il va trop vite
et ouais non c'est impossible c'est pas
possible on nous prend pour des cons
égaux mais si c'est là que ces six est
là et c'est possible oh [ __ ] j'y étais
presque à temps regarde les commentaires
non mais c'est pas possible a dit le cas
ivoirien
[Rires]
les gens prenaient pas mal c'est juste
qu'on veut pas trop s'attarder sur sa
valeur
l'épreuve était libre maintenant je ne
sens pas le truc ait beaucoup ça me tape
à ou ayew quoi fallait juste tenir là où
je suis amer de la porte au bout l epr
ouverte à temps mais pourquoi tu as
cassé ça chez moi a même été fait
romell broom et que tu vois tu la pub on
attend on va faire avec les moyens du
bord a tenté de venir là une manière
beaucoup plus tôt ouvert mes romans à
temps mais au nom urgo j'ai besoin de me
tp sur toi vas-y bien je suis là c'est
bon je trouve ça s'était ouverte à
l'heure et appuyez sur le bouton va
là-bas appuyé sur le bouton vas-y va
là-bas les appuis pour coco concours
concours pourtant
non a ajouté sue timing partie
une coiffure rue
est vachement bien c'est la guerre c'est
la guerre c'est la gare utb avec le
bouton à aa
oui
pour hugo
karim bonnet vraiment des gros le petit
pâté ou pas aisée
mais moi je m'en vais à bientôt
non non c'est long [ __ ] mais c'est
méga merde c'est super long avant je te
dis quand arrivait ou quand je suis
arrivée au pire rester genre dans mes
galons séméga non quoi ah ben voilà oui
là c'est au top c'est au top de la
longueur tarnais vgo faut qu'on trouve
le train fantôme sert à lever au moins
ça mais moi j'aimerais bien aimé [ __ ]
je repars en arrière il ya une bâche
c'est une arène la ushl merde et où je
suis mort j'ai sauté de 3 cm au but
allait bien et j'en mourrais mais via
l'asie vient on trouve le train fantôme
c'est pas possible a forcément un train
fantôme
je sais je les lucquois dans la
description du monde mais je te dis on
aurait dû mettre le mode ou enfin le
mode créative on aurait volé on aurait
vu un tas de fantômes à la mario là on
sera issue bah on peut le mettre non
l'art créatif
tiens j'ai comme par hasard je trouve
une pâques une pâques créative vient
taper tout sur moi tew a time carrément
genre mode gros chanson au top comme
gras vers garde au
mais du coup on veut leur envol comment
on fait comment avoir une fois il se
passe alors tu as eu une patinoire bic
non sérieux non maintenant à temps j'ai
ce passé attend cherche l'entrée on est
en mode gros cheaters normal cracher
atteinte chez hertz ont peut rentrer
c'est quoi ouais c'est une patinoire
mais qu elle vient je vais patiner
direct regarde comme on est bien on fait
comment pour aller dedans battant mais
parce qu'à la base il ya des en fait il
ya des entrées comme ça mais mais c'est
quoi cette arnaque
bon on fait comme ça tu sais quoi oh
merde
tata
là
allez on se casse allez on s'est
vraiment vol alors oui c'est plutôt
travaux tom alors attendez pas à voir mc
do t'es où
voilà c'est un mcdo là où on est la
regarde ça fait m
pensons à la haye battu samedi
ma devise y tester sein d'aig
bon alors y'a pas l'attraction la magic
dance amazighs on a testé sa web est dit
ou tu la tp tôt sur un bateau mère j'ai
envoyé un caméo jumelles magic the magic
dance comme d'habitude à mettre un petit
peu de musique parce que ça doit être
avec des et boiteux mois s'appelle c'est
bon je suis dedans boîte à musique
simplement
mais voilà où on me regarde tu m'a
bloqué mais comment commence à ce que je
fais pousser comme ça franchement au
[ __ ] tu mac et blu la vache et un
rhume accablant collet voilà c'est mon
indiqué m a dit qu attends je m'en
prends un [ __ ] attends je descends le
soulage le pen parce que mon métier pas
doué aussi mais attends faucon en paix
tu en voilà mm
alors voilà légende enfin trouvé cette
[ __ ] de tours infernales or c'est pas
la maison de l'europe c'est un truc pas
mal vas-y vas-y et regarde regarde à
gauche un seynois gros gardanne devant
la whey est ce que tu as déjà fait pour
de vrai cette attraction âge j'avais moi
j'ai déjà fait et c'est vraiment ça en
fait que ça s'arrête il ya il ya un mur
qui s'ouvre tu vois de voir tout le parc
et ça s'arrête ça refait ce nom c'est
pas mal explosé beau givet plus mais
quand il dit qu'il a finie le vidéo
après report les autres portent au
quotidien on est chaud là on va pas
s'arrêter on fait des à la vision ben
moi je kiffe bien donc pas de projet de
grave alors des flèches hockey flers
giguère
j'adore un arc voyait des arcs et faut
faire quoi
attends à on a des trucs avisé en beau
c'est pas genre si on touche une des
cibles ça explose a alors atteint l'asie
aya oculaire je n'ai pas couché
sarkozy annonce vise les mannequins pour
voir des films anne k way ou et regarde
way a ses limites
tout juste au dessus des bouchers à
temps mais c'est bien avec
c'est bon c'est bon et alors non non tu
te fous là bas il est tout ouïe 1
retrouve pas
ces revenus d'accords c'est tout
bon goût attends attends reflète celle
là l'arrêt à paris
fond
ce trop bon
et donc là et ça se remet fait chier on
se tait le chien a alors fait faut juste
ce petit truc qu'on attendait trop
instruits
ah bon elle est créative en forêt
snowshow réputé i'm s'arrête elle est
plein de danton pied ah bah ça ne fait
pas rire je jette pas la seule chose
dans le cul moi tu vas voir à soissons
tout moisi c'est dans l'art est un niqab
n'ont pas arrêté là si vous avez aimé
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à lâcher un
pouce vert je la ferai sûrement deux
parties vu le temps qu'elle a mis en
tout cas si ça vous a plu n'hésitez pas
à le dire en commentaire a lâché un
petit lac si vous voulez plus de
minecraft sur des maps fun et puis voilà
on se dit à bientôt un a sur une image
secondes sur mon frappe ce qui sur
ironman qui nous fait des frayeurs et
puis voilà tout le monde et à bientôt
pour sens tu à berne
[Musique]
non